un bonjour à tous cette semaine on est à
tokyo il a vu de toutes les
extravagances ça et comme on dit ici et
un segment serre
[Musique]
on est d'accord sur la piste
luc l'hôtesse de l'air vient quand même
de me demander si des japonais
maintenant 19 heures pour vol
tu vas forcément fatigué mais dieu que
[Musique]
comme fer
québec - ouais hein
[Musique]
tu vas tu connais la peep toe la carte
pas moi
[Applaudissements]
alors cet inconnu à paris les parisiens
font la gueule anglais japon savoir
jetons la gueule en japonais alors là on
est on est
on est perdu
ces vitraux
c'est la requête cela
[Musique]
on va voter chez mes passions j'ai
trouvé le plus what the fuck you what
the fuck un jeu vidéo de jetage de table
au principe c'était pas incarne un père
de famille ses nerfs parce que c'est
important d'être à la table de tout
tapage des balances attaque dans la
pièce
[Musique]
yes gt fia les négoces 18 points
et non ceci n'est pas une corde à
rideaux et bel et bien là que d'un chat
nous sommes dans un bar achats au coeur
de tokyo
on peut bien prendre une petite
collation et caresser ces animaux
[Musique]
la rencontre est le cousin japonais de
cergy s'appelle bateau comme un bateau
mais sauf que c'est son prénom s'écrira
pas trop
cet animal ne possède pas de visage
caméléon le chat en prison moi je ne
m'amuse pas vraiment un littoral est
matière à l'écran mignon c'est quand
même pas mal le chirurgien dans
l'adultère
nous voilà c'est fini
surtout barbecue
ce sont un peu inspiré de kung fu panda
pour le décor je vais leur dire et du
plagiat
[Musique]
5000 yens 5 c'est très bien 50 euros 50
j'aimais 50 euros
[Musique]
ça va donner du des forces ce temple
chez vous ou chez beaulieu sûr parce que
je suis plus les mecs ils ont des ps3
ils ont fait comme chaussures à plat
les premiers sushi japonais
n'existe que dans les sushis l'avocat et
le crabe ses sushis occidentalisée
américain prenez vous pas dans la phase
un vrai souci du japon hier l'avocat du
crabe
alors pour le tennis et le football avec
une sorte de deux pour un jeune comme ça
l'arrangé pas que windows
on va dire 3 2 je m'oppose toi aussi tu
mélanges évidemment
[Musique]
je n'ai pas envie
on dirait un masque pour la peau sous
forme liquide
je n'avais pas les cages du wasabi entre
le poisson et la bri ce n'est pas une
grosse bouchée de rage mais je suis un
homme paul sur les toits de tokyo c'est
fait
[Musique]
ça c'est très facile ça veut dire bike
sickle donc en anglais ces vélos donc ça
veut dire en gare à vélo au fait des
petits mots comme ça que je connais sa
culture j'ai quoi
[Musique]
cette semaine deux policiers à tokyo
hawaï comme je vous l'aï les fermer le
puits en fleurs alors comment ici pour
les gâteaux et sanaa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]